what do you think of all this live work
um
we live ideas i really thought that this
could be something with
micro apartments i got obsessed with it
micro homes
i was looking for an investment we wound
up investing in blockable.com which
builds modular housing in factories
slightly different than micro apartments
or these adus accessibility dwelling
units or whatever
what impact are those going to have in
the future on cities and do you think
those are a good thing for us to pursue
with this housing crisis micro
apartments we live
clubs yeah great question uh in uh
constraints supply constrained cities
like san francisco new york
um austin yeah i see it like i i i've
helped a couple of investors who've
looked at opportunities here and like
there's definitely demands and
there's an arbitrage play right just
like master lease something chop it into
smaller bits and
lease it again to kind of people renting
yeah um do i think
it will work in the rest of america
which isn't a supply constraint because
most u.s rental markets or real estate
markets are kind of one for one
there's there's no crazy imbalance of
demand and supply we just happen to live
in a
crazy imbalanced city um unclear
maybe um millennials are still to your
earlier question
highly footloose don't even necessarily
want to commit to a 12 month lease
uh less than anything longer so i'm kind
of long on it in the first 10 cities
that they've all focused on in the we
lives in the commons uh totally buy it
the biggest challenge for them i think
will be does this work in lansing
michigan or does it need to work in like
smaller cities or is there enough supply
where you can have your own place
but the reason i think is interesting is
if you think about
low-cost value products like lift line
or uber pool
um and just saving money and being
frugal in order to have
for the for the millennials and these
gen z's who really value your lifestyle
part of the having this epic lifestyle
is not having a big burn rate
yep so in a place like san francisco
micro apartments or manhattan new york
or hong kong a micro apartment which i
think is 150 square feet to
250 square feet this is right yeah 350 i
think was the limit in new york that you
weren't allowed to build less than that
because they didn't want
families living in under 350 square feet
but they didn't realize that there would
be single people all over the place
so the reason to have that here would be
somebody could pay
2 000 instead of what is the average
rent in san francisco now
thirty seven hundred dollars is that
number legit or does that include like
these five thousand dollar high-end
apartments
skew it so zom pepper has pretty much
every listing in san francisco to be
clear these are vacant listings being
advertised on zumper
right now so this is not saying your
neighbor who's been in their apartment
for seven years is paying 3700.
um the last report yeah here it is down
a little
um to 35 20. new york is 3000 boston
2500
san jose 2400 los angeles 22. los
angeles seems high to me
um and san diego 1750 for a one bedroom
yeah it's
san francisco has been above new york
for several years now it's actually
narrowing a little but there's no signs
that anything's gonna
gonna the difference here is in new york
that's new york new york
five bars five boroughs yep now here's
the thing
if you live in new york and you live out
in flatbush or crown heights
that number is not three thousand it's
correct fourteen hundred 1400
1500 yeah this is very bimodal this is a
very bimodal average you've got a bunch
of people in manhattan paying five and a
half k
and a bunch of people in queens paying
2k right and
they can each use the city equally
correct because of
transportation transportation and that's
what's missing here is i lived on the
last stop
bay ridge brooklyn yep
but i could go to manhattan it just took
me 20 or 30 more minutes
but same train yep that the people in
the upper east i took yeah
so i had to suffer like an extra 30
minutes boohoo for me as a young person
i didn't care
still part of it once i got to the
limelight once i got to the palladium
once i got to manhattan
the rock see the tunnel all these great
clubs back in the day it didn't matter
to me if it took me 20 more minutes then
i was in the club
like it was lit yeah you didn't remember
on the way back [ __ ] i care if it took
me 20 extra minutes on the subway and
you know what i took the subway home at
four in the morning five in the morning
we'll go get we would go to florence
steak freeze
it's safe as well i i lived in new york
as well yeah it's fine yeah yeah i mean
as long as you're not dumb i mean
if it's after midnight go to the middle
car where the conductor is
or the first car where the conductor is
that's all if you're alone
now if you had micro apartments what
would they
be in each of these top cities you'd
think as a percentage
of cost what do you think that would
actually cost to do because the average
apartment is five six seven hundred
square feet
eight hundred yeah sure what's a one
bedroom 900 yeah
800 800 yeah so you could probably get
that down
you could probably have two micro is
that right two for one you think
yeah roughly i think i mean there are
people in san francisco to use us as an
example
against the 35 20 you'll pay if you take
a one bedroom there are people in
co-living spaces paying just over a
thousand bucks